let's go to Austin Texas the one city in
Texas that I have ever visited other
than airports I guess there's a serial
bomber wreaking havoc in Austin Texas
and this started a little over two weeks
ago March 2nd was the first bombing a
package
I guess the USPS calls it a parcel blew
up when a 39 year old named Anthony
Stefan house was killed picking up a
package bomb
March 12th two more packages explode
within just a few hours of each other
the first one killed 17-year old cello
estai believe he was drill and Mason and
also injured a woman the second injured
a 75 year old Hispanic woman and now
yesterday the fourth of these bombs
injured two people there is the idea
that race may be a factor here because
of the first three bombings injured or
killed black or Hispanic people
exclusively I think I believe that's
right the most recent bomb from
yesterday used the tripwire mechanism
and injured white people and that seems
to be sort of a shift in a different
direction in terms of the tactics of the
bomber presuming that this is the same
individual and police so far haven't
been definitive about that but they're
saying that certainly the Patterson
pattern that seems to point in that
direction the source of the bombs is not
clear causing total chaos and Austin
Police are telling people in entire
neighborhoods to stay home near where
the bomb went off
school buses won't be going to the same
neighborhood today and it's unclear when
school bus service is going to resume
and there's now $100,000 reward and a
fifteen thousand dollar reward for any
leads that result in the eventual
conviction of the shooter police also
asking or the bomber route rather police
also asking the bomber to get in touch
with them and that I've read online that
some people are saying why are the
police saying give us a call that never
happens it's actually something more
common than you might imagine oftentimes
these bombers hostage-takers Barrack
haters they want communication with
others and the tactic of saying we're
ready to talk we want to talk to you we
want to figure out what it is that's
to do this it can actually be more in
fact more effective than you can imagine
and of course no shortage of stupidity
triggered by these bombings one example
the region school of austin said that
today they were going to be having a
two-hour delay for the start of school
it's a private Christian school and the
statement they put out says quote
Christians know that what man intends
for evil God will use for his glory
please remind your children that our
Lord is now and continues to be in
control despite what we see or hear
although this tragic tragic event hits
close to our community let us be
resolved in what and who we look to in
times as this could you imagine a more
meaningless statement because if God was
controlling everything wouldn't he just
have prevented the bombings in the first
place oh well God works in mysterious
ways right and it's not just nutty
religious talk it's also conspiracy
theories when a bombing takes place in
the backyard of Infowars as Alex Jones
you can expect conspiracy theories and
there are a ton Alex Jones himself
suggesting that the racial motivation
here the apparent racial motivation
might be a false flag with the goal of
starting a race war and that may be an
Tifa is behind the entire thing here's
Alex Jones losing his mind what do you
make of this oh let me just make this
statement is an tyfa behind the third
bombing here's the question is an tyfa
behind the now third bombing in austin
texas they're violent they call for
violence they call for attacking
gentrification any old white people
moving in to east austin and you have
three bombings that have happened they
also say old hispanics are old blacks if
you're not from the neighborhood you're
not wanted I'm just saying I think that
they should be investigated because they
are a terror group they're listed as a
terror group they call for violence yeah
listen I have no actual reason to think
an Tifa has anything to do with this but
definitely investigate and Tifa then
mike Serna vich who has previously
attacked me also tweeting a few days ago
that it's too soon to know what's
happening in austin texas but
worth noting that bombs are
traditionally a left-wing and Tifa
method of terrorism and then here's one
more clip a so-called reporter for
Infowars suggesting that the bombings in
Austin Texas might be tied to Muslim
London Mayor Sadiq Khan
apparently visiting Austin Texas I can't
even understand this one Anders is out
here it just kind of becomes a hub for
stuff Sadiq Khan will be around at Tara
oh oh oh you know what oh wow oh wow
when did Sadiq Khan get to Austin Texas
is Sadiq Khan in Austin Texas right now
we're gonna have to look into that
because Sadiq Khan said that when he's
the mayor of a city terrorism is part
and parcel so then he arrives in Austin
and then you have two explosions so I'm
just reporting on things that right
happen here he's just making the report
nice neat little conspiracy there huh I
can't really make stuff up on that one
could be listen I don't know whether
Sadiq Khan is here but he might be here
and well there you go B that's something
we've absolutely got a look into isn't
it I liked how the cameraman was saying
all this stuff it's like he's
auditioning for a reporter's job
who's the cameraman the guy that was
talking in the background you didn't
hear that during that little exchange he
was offering all oh no I didn't oh yeah
I only heard his ideas 401 shroyer
they're the Kok correspondent was the
only one I heard there yeah it's a
family affair over there at Infowars
everybody's saying hey listen this
couldn't possibly be what it most
appears to be it must be something
either related to a Muslim mayor or a
so-called left-wing anti-fascist group
because everything is a false flag in
all seriousness this is absolutely
terrorizing people in Austin I have
friends in Austin who don't even live
near where this has been going on and
everybody is just afraid of packages you
get a package you don't know what to do
it could be a package that potentially
at least has some kind of bond that
you're going to trigger by opening it so
hopefully this will all come to a
resolution soon with no more violence
and injury and it is being discussed on
our subreddit which you can access at
david pakman.com slash re d di t today's
program is brought to you in
part by Celsius which is a new global
peer-to-peer financial platform that
connects holders of cryptocurrency
assets with borrowers and it will also
allow crypto holders to earn interest on
their assets in the form of coins or get
US dollar loans against their crypto
assets it's sort of like how having a
savings account at a bank works right
just by having crypto in your Celsius
wallet you'll earn interest on that
crypto but unlike a bank
this is blockchain based your coins
become part of a decentralized and
crowd-sourced lending pool and you'll be
able to earn interest daily without the
profits going to traditional financial
institutions and you can instantly
borrow against your own coins and
Celsius intends to lend only with
single-digit interest rates regardless
of credit score and Celsius sort of
wants to stick it to Wall Street and
revolutionize the financial industry and
they are running an ICO
an initial coin offering which you can
learn more about at Celsius dot Network
slash crowd sale in the US it's open
only to accredited investors and you can
sign up at Celsius dot Network slash
crowd sale this is not financial advice
please do your own research and due
diligence before making any financial
decision